Facebook's drive to become your next TV
takes flight today a new video platform
is being launched with original content
just for viewing on Facebook
it's called watch and is available to a
select group of users today Disney is
also creating its own streaming service
and removing the company's content from
Netflix all this could affect the way
you find your shows movies and videos
Robert's safe in his editor and managing
director of Fast Company good morning
good morning morning good morning to you
let's talk about Facebook first what how
is this platform gonna work and what the
content that's gonna be on it yes so
this is really a shot across the bow to
YouTube that's really who Facebook is
initially going after with this it's its
creator its content it's it's part of an
ongoing really war battle between the
big tech companies as they're expanding
into each other's areas more and more
that's really what's going on here and
Disney doing the same thing by soon and
in our own content we don't need you to
do it right well it is Disney's is is
again it's the it's the cross Disney and
Netflix Disney went to Netflix because
they needed streaming technology right
Netflix went to Disney because they
needed content well Netflix is now
creating a lot more of its own content
Disney spent two and a half billion
dollars buying a company called BAM tech
they have their own streaming technology
this competition continues to intensify
across across all of these different
platforms right but YouTube remains you
know the the the 800-pound gorilla and
this people spend a billion hours a day
watching YouTube videos a billion hours
a day so Facebook has advantages that
they can that they can exploit to try to
expand to get into that territory but
YouTube at this point has that has the
big advantage what kind of content is it
that will be streaming on Facebook well
at this point they have some premium
content they are paying some folks for
some content but a lot of it is by the
kinds of creators that have historically
populated have historically populated
YouTube that that Facebook will will
exploit now one of the things I spent
some time with Mark Zuckerberg earlier
this year and he is constantly iterating
he's continuing to move and improve so
wherever Facebook is today that doesn't
mean they're not going to be someplace
else tomorrow what will the networks do
well the
works are at this point what is the
difference between a network between the
televisions channel between a cable
channel between an app between a website
right all of these lines have been
blurring and particularly on mobile
devices as we go to 5g as we move toward
broader bandwidth across our phones all
these lines are gonna blur even more
where and when people watch content from
a consumers point of view we're gonna
have more choices in more ways than we
ever did before from a business point of
view who's gonna win all bets are off
everyone is trying to get into everyone
else's business during your chat with
Zuckerberg did you talk about the spread
of misinformation on Facebook and what
he's doing to combat that the extremist
views that you sometimes see on your
Facebook feed we did talk about that a
little bit and again he sees these
challenges as being challenges that can
be sir Matthews very much in engineers
mindset right you have a problem you see
it you address it you fix it you make it
better over time and you move on to the
next thing and that's what he believes
that hey that Facebook can do and will
continue to do it goes for problems it
goes for opportunities is he gonna run
for president he didn't share that with
me I'm not sure that's in his plans in
the near term there is speculation there
is speculation but I think he's got a
pretty big platform that he's already
I'm charge of running it's keeping busy
regardless thank you very much Robert
Safian thank you